hey girl hi how are you
i'm good i want to know about your
valentine's day
weekend oh oh well you know it's in
so bradley went back to nashville so we
had a really cute facetime dinner
date so he ordered food we ate over face
time
i know and then of course you know
flowers and we exchanged
gifts and stuff but he had to go back to
nashville so we did it thank goodness
for technology over face time i know
it's so crazy i love that the two of you
guys you met on a dating app like i
don't think people realize that
celebrities need to use
apps too we're we're humans
yeah and also we have crazy schedules
that don't always
provide time or opportunity to meet
people because you don't necessarily
want to date someone you're working with
true all right you kind of want to keep
that separate yeah um
and so it's just helpful and it's not
something that i ever thought would
actually
happen and the fact that we knew so many
of the same people i was like oh
it was a matter of time i suppose that
we would meet and
a dating app happened to be it so hey
do you think it took a long time to
convince him that it was really you
or anything else no i think he already
well
this is what you shouldn't do ladies
make sure you put some
information because i was like i tried
to be slick and i'm like oh if people
actually
care about getting to know me they'll
ask questions as opposed to just like oh
she happens to be on a tv show
and he's like i really thought it was
sort of a catfish for
you know the better part of our
first conversation and so i
he didn't ask for a while about even you
know work or any of that jess
so i was like oh maybe he doesn't care
maybe he doesn't know he's not a fan of
the show great
great great so um yeah i think for a
minute he was like
is she real and especially since i
didn't have too much i don't think i had
anything really on the bio but just but
pictures that were like personal
pictures
yeah you know that you couldn't find on
instagram that
were pictures that i don't know i would
think that sort of
confirmed that it's me but however i
would feel the same way
i would feel the same way so ladies
people gentlemen
put some of them in your bio okay anyway
make sure you do it
yeah oh my gosh okay so let's talk about
music
the remix to your single feel good is a
vibe
okay thank you and the song is about
just embracing yourself you know
inner confidence self love all of that
you know
when did you learn to put yourself first
oh uh i'm still learning it's a work in
progress
i there are so many times i mean i come
from
uh a place of people pleasing and
i don't want to disappoint people and
that was sort of the lot in my family
um and i was the entertaining diplomat
so i want to make sure everybody's okay
and then you realize oh while you're
making sure and managing other people's
feelings you're not managing and making
sure you're okay
and so that of course where the song was
born from is that like
you really got to be in the business of
taking care of yourself because you
can't you won't be good to anyone else
if you're not
and so yeah it's a work in progress i
mean it's definitely something i have to
be
cognizant of and i'm like oh wait am i
making this decision
for what reason is it for myself is it
for the betterment
is it because i don't want to disappoint
someone so it's always about intention
but yes a work in progress i'm working
on it
yeah yeah you know the ongoing
global health crisis has obviously
affected us in so many ways um
but what do you do to keep yourself in a
positive mindset
well there's a lot of meditation a lot
of prayer
a lot of you know reading things that
sort of
get me away from the distractions of
comparing and despairing like instagram
or anything on
the internet um anything that sort of
just puts me at ease i love baths music
you know um that stuff for me is
oh have i done something for myself
today whether it's
fill in the blank whether it's a book
you wanted to read a bath you wanted to
take or
you know a book you want yeah whatever i
mean there's
everybody's so different but i and i'm
different day to day but i just think if
you
can set the tone for your day obviously
i have a list of gratitude that i start
the day with but if you can just have
one thing
that you can set the tone for your day
with i think it's really
advantageous so that's what i try to do
you just gave me a guide to feel good
i'm trying we're all trying
now i know you're hard at work on the
debut album how is that coming along
like
how many songs are we thinking how many
songs do you love already like how far
are we in this
i mean we're pretty i mean i pretty much
have an album it's just
deciding what songs are going to make
the album yeah i know that we have two
other songs coming out for the ep
um one song very soon to come out
called girl go and it's basically
the 21 year old chrissy leaving
gainesville florida to come out to la to
pursue her dreams and it's really that
that sentiment and that feeling and then
another really great song um i'll leave
that for later
um so that will be the ep and then we'll
roll out the album i just don't know
when i don't have any firm dates yet so
but we got it we got up we got
everything
yeah um how would you describe your
sound because i know that you're
assigned to the country division
of universal music but i wouldn't define
your sound as just country
yeah that's the tricky part and because
i've been influenced by so many genres
i mean if i had to put i would say maybe
like country soul
you know maybe yeah
yeah i like that um you know we're
talking with you as a part of crs
and a big part of that is shining a
light on emerging artists so
what's your advice to someone who wants
to follow in your footsteps and maybe is
feeling discouraged
oh boy i think the biggest part always
is to come back to your intention
why is it that you want to create music
why do you want to tell the stories
why do you love music and i think if you
always can be rooted in
doing things for the right reasons and
not because you want fame or fortune
or you know overnight success um
following your heart you know you're
given a vision you're never given a
vision without a provision
so it's placed upon your heart you got
to do it no matter what it is
and with music what's beautiful is that
you can create it even if you don't have
an audience
yeah you know so just keep creating just
keep
just immersing yourself into that world
and if you know i really firmly believe
that's what what's meant for you
will find you no matter what so even if
you try to run away from it
but i think that there's nothing there's
no substitute for hard work
and for passion and that's what's i
think most important
i love that yeah obviously the road to
success is
a long road and before you did this for
a living
you know what was one of the worst
non-music related jobs you've ever had
i i don't know about worst because i
really i'm i try to be a positive polly
i really do
i think one of my toughest jobs and it
was because when i was you know 15 16
i worked at mcdonald's and it's hard
work like
we're talking lifting dealing with
customers like
smelling like french fries which can be
good or bad i mean it's
it was definitely um a foundation for
work ethic and also to just learn how to
communicate um but it was difficult
it was hard and our particular store was
right off of the interstate
so we always were slammed and crazy busy
so um
it was hard work but i mean aside from
from that and i mean i taught preschool
and i babysat a lot
nannied and i i don't know if i had the
worst job i just always
had jobs that were hard but i think
every job is hard right
so yeah yeah
so tomorrow you're headed back to work
apparently
yeah this is us yeah
yeah yeah it's first of all the fact
that we even get to have
this season is really wonderful because
there's a lot of shows that aren't
able back because of you know cost and
budget
and stuff is getting good things are
getting good
um you've seen the last episode we
weren't sure
um if kate and toby were going to be
taking their little babe home
so yeah you know this they really it was
so emotional that particular episode
i don't have children but like seeing
all the the babies
you know it was just like oh um
yeah so we're gonna see how kate and
toby um
are gonna finagle this new this
really beautiful new addition to their
family and is it going to affect their
relationship
yes mostly i know you've told us in the
past that
you watch the show and you also cry yes
so given you've already seen the script
and i know you can't give me anything
yeah on a scale of one to ten
how much tissue am i gonna need well
let's see these next couple episodes
maybe not too much
i think um maybe not too much but i do
think that um coming down toward the end
of this season
you don't need some dishes yeah
probably like a little travel pack oh
just
the with a little like the little yeah
oh
okay probably that that seems that seems
right
yeah um how has this
as us changed your life like i know that
you were financially on the verge of
being broke before you were finding it
difficult and you were coming to
hollywood to land roles and whatnot
i think that your story is so incredibly
inspiring so
i know you gave advice earlier to
emerging talent
um that was incredible and i know you're
making a song you know go girl and all
that but
how has this us changed your life
well i think it's instilled confidence
in that you got to suit up and show up
for yourself
and there are days that i'm like i don't
know if i'm an actress like i don't know
if i'm good at this i don't know
and i'm like christy just suit up and
show up and leave the rest
and because it's a collaborative art
there are many people
who get to have their opinions and their
really great perspective
and their experience and i'm like let me
just trust the process
so it's really helped me to not only
instill confidence in myself because
every single time you show up for
yourself you
are instilling that confidence because
confidence is just trust in yourself
and so when you have that you're like
okay i trust that the last 10 times
i survived i showed up i did what i was
told to do
and what felt right and look where it's
led me so
in that way it's really developed um
me spiritually mentally emotionally for
um just showing up in a room and humbly
showing up in a room or just
um knowing that i don't have to
feel entitled but i am deserving and i
think all of us
should feel that way and so it's created
of course
incredible opportunity and financial
stability that i never had
ever in my life but also
so much more of um a spiritual journey
in my process in my you know
bigger bigger journey and so yeah it's
changed
me completely so awesome have more faith
than fear
yes hello
i love what you represent you are so
incredibly multi-talented
i'm excited about this project and just
thank you for being you i hope you have
a great day
thank you youtube good to see you good
to see you grizzy bye droopy chrissy
bye bye bye queen
bye queen
you